comedy is where I'm from the process of  doing sketch comedy you know week after  week on on key and peel very much became  about this idea of of Jiu Jitsu of Judo  if you can predict where an audience is  going to go or what they think you're  going to do you can use that momentum  against them you know all over this  movie I knew I wanted to have reveals I  knew I wanted to have twists but most  importantly you know I figured if an  audience thinks they know what's going  on whether they like it or they don't if  you can show them that they've been  watching something completely different  the entire time I think they have a  respect and there's a there's a real  intellectual catharsis that comes with  that and and and and it's fulfilling for  an audience